So we can also talk about near, total unconsciousness, coma for instance. In
fact, a coma is brain activity so you're not dead.but its just one step up from
being dead. For instance, my brother back in the 90s was involved in a very
serious accident. He was riding his bike home from work. And the woman who was
driving the car turned right into him, didn't see him, and he hit the
windshield. He went into a serious coma, very deep coma, for two weeks. And
then for about six months, he was vegetative. His eyes were open but he was
still really quite non-responsive. So during this time, he went from near death
to a very gradual awakening in consciousness. In fact, I kept wondering what
was he aware of? Was he aware of anything? Could he hear us? Could he think?
Could he remember? We just didn't know.